welcome back to the Grand Chester in
Zagreb how does it feel to be playing in
the city
it felt great I mean it's the
continuation of the grandchester tour
for me in a way it feels like the
beginning of a new season because I took
a long break after
Bucharest in that sense it feels like
I'm ready to to start a new season and
of course at the beginning there's
always some there's uncertainty because
you you never know how it will go but
then after a couple of rounds you
realize that it's uh all the same it's
as usual so yeah very much looking
forward to this one it feels great
especially after the last year where I
played quite a good chess and this year
I'll be able to play in both events
rapid and Blitz and I'm really looking
forward to it to it and for me it's for
me personally this is one of the most
important tournaments in a year now it's
really great I mean I'm in a very
vocational mood because also it's first
time for me to visit Croatia I really
like it it has this
kind of volcanic I feel the atmosphere
of actually Yugoslavian countries
I played here every time a little bit
strange tournaments but I hope this year
I can play good tournament
I like sagreb and this year I come with
my friends to enjoy from Zagreb walk
and also I hope with my friends I will
play much better I would say it's one of
my favorite countries probably
you know mostly because of you know the
southern part like split uh
it's just very nice I mean I really
enjoy spending time there but here in
Zagreb is also like very very nice city
center and we are we like to stay here
and I'm really looking forward to spend
some time like walking around the city
oh yeah it's great to be here actually
again since I was here last year as well
so yeah it's just for me it's a big
honor to be part of the grand Chester
it's all the biggest gesture in the
world and all the best players are
playing here so for me it's a big you
know opportunity to play against the
best players in the world and to try and
do my best here let's say and get some
points with them yeah I like it here in
Croatia so I've been happy to to go
outside to you know recognize a few
spots I know here and yeah I have to to
be able to
not only play chess Play Good chess but
also visit again just by turning offside
web I am very happy and pleased and I'd
like to thank granchester the sponsors
and organizer for our whole thing
another event I had a pretty lackluster
result in Poland the same format so I'm
hoping to be able to bounce back but I'm
very excited this tournament is going to
be stronger than ever and very pleased
to be here hopefully I put enough
preparation to play well yes it feels
great I've been here once during
European Team Championship
it was not organized here but we took a
car and came it's a very good City
especially in summer it feels very good
and the tournament is there is a very
good quality tournament so I'm happy to
be here feels very good to be here back
in in Zagreb it's really one of my my
favorite cities I had a great time here
last time I was here now I arrived just
yesterday but I've had some time today
to have a have a long walk
and see the city again and it's it's
nice to be here very comfortable in
terms of
temperature as well so that's it's good
[Music]